Tiger Woods breaks his silence after  being arrested for suspicion of driving  under the influence the 41 year old golf  pro released a statement nearly 12 hours  after being placed in a Palm Beach  County Jail following his arrest early  Monday morning in Jupiter Florida  he told CBS News in part quote I want  the public to know that alcohol was not  involved what happened was an unexpected  reaction to prescribe medications I  didn't realize the mix of medications  had affected me so strongly Woods also  apologized to his family friends and  fans he promised he's doing everything  in his power to ensure it never happens  again